we never consider why can't I just go
all the way to the top and the reason
why is that we are socialized or taught
to believe or believe for whatever
reason that we should always consider
incrementalism first well and before I
can open the big lemonade business I
first have to have the lemonade stand
and that is a very corrupt interesting
but my bias and your bias is why can't I
be the best God I wouldn't say to be the
best like why wouldn't you want that
confidence and ambition is not
delusional ego it's a framework of
perspective to try dreaming and and
strategizing
and then executing it's important if you
shoot for the top of that house
you're definitely not going to a
mountain
if you shoot for the moon you're by
accident gonna end up on that mountain
on your way to the Moon understand